this is a good opportunity to jump over
to our next segment yeah guess you're
right
yeah that's a good boy we go oh man what
a world we live in
- fat professors what they had to say
that are afraid of kovat night teen
causing fat phobia all right first of
all let me just show you this from the
CDC website groups at higher risk for
severe severe illness and you can see
people with severe obesity body mass
index BMI of 40 or higher well for TOI
that's really City it's a bigger yes big
and so this is people who are at risk
for kovin so right now my we were
talking about this and and we were like
somebody's got to do a video on this and
I just call out these body positivity
obese people who have like they've
they've encouraged this bad behavior
which is now getting people sick and
hurt so here we have this story from
April 5th campus reform says here all
here's a picture I guess to University
of wisconsin-la Crosse professors who
call themselves the two fat professors
oh that's literally was way to call them
so there you go
our concern that coronavirus is causing
fatphobia Darcy Thune author of a my fat
you are in the International fat studies
handbook what Oh recently that he's a
great guy yes recently published a blog
post on the website to fit professors
calm the piece titled diet culture at
the end of the world outlines Thune's
opinion regarding weight gain during the
Cova 19 crisis to their credit they will
they will to a certain degree survive
longer than say like the soy boys
because of the energy stored in their
body yeah but they're gonna be out of
out of out of shape they can't run so
right so when the critters the the the
large beasts come hungry they're gonna
find to plump slow but here's the good
news
can I say can I say a bad joke an
off-color joke yes the good news is that
you don't have to run faster than the
bear you just have to run faster than
the two fat professors yeah all i could
think of is every zombie movie there's
always that big big zombie yeah or the
big person and they're like well the
zombies will get that person and they do
okay here we go
they say every time soon wrote her piece
diet coke
in the world in response to the many
number of posts that have popped up on
her social media sites addressing fears
about weight gain according to the
professor these posts shame viewers for
not going to the gym for eating too much
for getting fat and for not starving
ourselves the end of the world and our
representative of a problematic diet
culture the blog post repeatedly refers
to those who are cognizant of their
weight as part of a diet culture foon
criticizes those who speak out against
weight gain and characterize it as
dangerous saying they feed into a system
of fat phobia that oppresses and abuses
so many oh man I quote I think the
author is portraying something that
isn't an issue
Brandon message a sophomore at UW La
Crosse and campus reform course monic
told campus our forum
you know why I take the biggest issue
with these of all of the SJW weirdos
please it's a choice yeah yeah I was
watching there's a commercial that airs
on Fox all the time and it's like it's
like are you overweight and struggling
it may actually be due to a to a
condition called insulin resistance and
if you take this medication or whatever
and I'm like that just means you eat too
much sugar right exactly it's like it's
theirs I watch the show I camera but it
was but there was this woman who was
really overweight and all of these
people kept saying that the reason they
were overweight was because of genetics
right and there and they were adamant
they didn't even eat that much and so
they were they were asked like how often
do you eat and they wrote down like for
breakfast I have this for lunch I have
this for dinner I have this now how
often do they exercise
oh no no no no hold on go on yeah in the
in what they wrote down they said like
for breakfast I have you know like two
eggs and like some toast and a bowl of
oatmeal for lunch I have a sandwich and
for dinner I have a small light you know
dinner and so looking after Lexie it's
only at 1,700 calories it must be
genetic so they filmed them yeah yeah
and guess what they ate all the time
non-stop all day they were eating yeah
they would be alike they would eat their
breakfast yes like they said yeah and
then like a like half an hour later
they'd walk in the kitchen and grab like
a bag of chips and you start eating
chips yeah and then they'd have lunch
like they said and they would walk in
the kitchen and and grab some snacks and
some cookies mm-hmm and they were so
they were confronted and the doctors
were like this is what you said you ate
today right and they're like what about
all of this they show
the videos and they're like I was just
snacking and they're like you snapped
like 2,000 calories yeah like each of
those cookies was like a hundred
calories right and they're like oh no
way the snacks have calories you know
what man
oh man that's here's look I'm all about
freedom life liberty and pursuit of
happiness sure if you want to eat
cookies all day do it with my blessing I
do not care but the people who want to
call you an oppressor because you don't
eat cookies all day right or because you
would tell someone I'm concerned about
your health these people are insane so
there are like a going that there is
going too far for instance my Louie
innopolis fat-shamed a guy at the gym
yes and I'm like what dude that's Jim
he's actually working out trying to
better himself
yeah you should taking a picture with
him and been like this guy's doing it
right exact this guy's you know he's
doing no and whatever and but then
there's the inversion which is she's
claiming it's a weird diet culture
shaming people for not going to the gym
that's so weird
go for a walk man breathe some air
outside yeah I mean it just wonders
what's really cool right now about the
shutdown is the air is so clean nice
dude we were looking outside the
backyard and we were like whoa look at
all the stars yeah I'm like whoa could
that be because like Philly has no smog
right now yeah maybe yeah you can
actually see stars there's still light
pollution but it's like all clear it is
crazy the amount of stars that I can see
outside yeah it's awesome shall we shall
we get to the conspiracy theory yeah
let's go are you all ready for this wait
till you see just how deep this this fat
conspiracy goes now I don't even I don't
even know if we you know said it was a
conspiracy but I'm dishonest now it's a
conspiracy put on a show buddy that's
great now I myself enjoy a good pint of
Ben and Jerry's they've actually got an
almond milk version now it's it it is
vegan and there is the delicious creamy
and there's the craziest one they have
is what the core you ever see the core
Ben & Jerry's absolutely insane don't
they have a social justice one - its
disgusting
dude we will that's not really surprised
it was quite spicy Brown yes oh yeah we
got it I'm like I'll try the Browning I
was like I want to try the justice remix
and I and I ate and I'm like why is my
ice cream spicy so you think it's sweet
but then when you try it it's actually
really fiery and and you know what it
says spicy on it right but the this core
one they have its liquid brownie batter
in the middle it's just like liquid it's
it's it's it's it's like kind of frozen
okay but yeah it's like it's like batter
so you're you're injecting sugar
straight near veins never have I
encountered a dessert so insanely
fattening I'm not I mean you know what
I'm not that big of a sweet kind of a
thick person I don't I don't do sweets
very often I like savory stuff well but
the conspiracy yeah sure you know we
enjoy about injuries I know you guys you
guys are sitting there geeking out on
ice cream I figured I'd have some to say
check us out oh boy what do we see okay
you can't really see it but you can see
right here what does that say Ben and
Jerry's parent it says Unilever a
British Dutch transit transit national
consumer goods company they're the
parent company for Ben and Jerry's I
wonder who else they're apparent now
hold on for well done do you remember
the real beauty campaign which is one of
the first campaigns about being proud to
be fat oh yeah by Dove toiletries the
soap company I do remember them now who
owns Dove Unilever what conspiracy
theory yep the parent company knows that
they've got a bunch of fat women who eat
their ice cream who feel bad when they
use beautiful skinny models so how do
you keep them buying your soap and
buying your ice cream real beauty
campaign yep dove comes out shows all
these plus-size models and then sells
them Ben and Jerry's I'm come kidding I
really don't get second Spira see I
think dove you know what I think it's
really happening
Americans are just typically fat like
40% of Americans are overweight yeah and
so these but the reason why you're
seeing fat superheroes mostly women like
it's like really fat female superheroes
is because they're trying to cater
the people who are fat it seems like it
so it's it's really the simple if 10%
your population is fat it's a small
market share and so people are gonna
market to them because it's a it's not
path towards a successful business when
40% of your population are don't be
surprised when these these you know
these fat professors come out and start
saying that like you're fat phobic and
you're an oppressor the reason why so
many feminists are agreeing with it is
because they're fat they're fat and they
want an excuse for why they don't to be
responsible for their weight but I'll
make sure it's clear I don't care if you
want to eat pizza and ice cream all day
and you get fat I care that you're
trying to claim I'm oppressing you by
not doing that or by encouraging
healthier living right that's a problem
yeah don't even say something yeah this
made me really mad when I was losing
weight because they were turning me into
some kind of oppressor because I was
actually trying to lose weight and
actually kind of succeeding at it slowly
it's very slow process it requires a lot
of adjustment and it requires a lot of
like going against the grain because all
of these people will tell you you're
being oppressed if you're trying to lose
weight or worse yet you are oppressing
other people I think it's really simple
I think there we used to have a culture
of striving to be better yeah now we
have now now we're a culture of
participation trophies yeah
striving to be mediocre it's not just
that it's like what they're saying is
literally a participation trophy
striving to be comfortable think think
about what a participation trophy is
just for showing up you get an award
it's not even just that it's it's like
striving to be a victim you're trying to
be the bottom of the totem pole and
they'll get you'll get to all these
points in the sympathy and you really I
mean you've overcome a lot or whatever
you've had a lot of stacked up against
you what a weird pendulum swing strange
to me I agree remember when Barack Obama
said the American dream is to be Donald
Trump what it was he said there right I
think I robbed rappers did yeah that
let's even look it up because it might
just be a meme that someone made up he's
in there's a bunch of songs talking
about Obama say oh I don't know if Obama
said it but I have no it's like I listen
it really is I mean not only is it
billionaire became the beacon
president I know like like say whatever
you want about that where does he go
from here yeah nopes is calling the same
mixture Oh which means it's true oh wait
you actually use and Trust Snopes what
was the first thing that came up so I
was like you know all right what do they
say nope nope they're gonna do the meme
oh let's see
thanks Obama they're gonna say mixture
while it is true he did say it the image
that was using the meme is not true they
do start one of their sentences Wow Oh
final sentences while some of these
articles clarified Obama's meaning in
the text the headline claims presented
were a mischaracterization of their
argument so he said it pretty sure he
knows whatever man he didn't say it
while eating ice cream but what's that
what's the context they're trying to
bring up like Obama was insulting Trump
person has one example of this pragmatic
approach Obama suggested reframing the
quest for racial equality as part of the
American concept of equality and
opportunity what I don't understand what
they're trying to say nopes is just
doing right now poorly and I hate them
so we get Snopes he did say you did
definitely say so yeah you can be a rich
guy like Trump and they hate him and
they're the antithesis yeah they strive
to be bad at everything it's incredible
and we proud of it though well what a
weird part we used to have superheroes
that was so proud of being bad I know
it's that's or fat well they put it in
their profile thei they're like I'm
disabled and I'm a man poor and no this
isn't this and I'm on food stamps or
whatever and I'm like what is there to
be proud of here what are you talking
about you know it's funny though
I want your sympathy so you that's what
I've seen you had fascists in Europe
that were like uber uber men supremacist
types that were like everyone must be
this perfect way now you have an
inversion of that where they're like
we're all pathetic losers with brain
problems and we're overweight and
victims and when you get a regular
person saying like I'm really sorry
that's happening you know um perhaps you
could try exercise yeah and they call
you a fascist now yep because to them
you being a regular person advocating
for healthier living and exercise is
like the same day
to a regular person to the fascist you
know I mean basic like they've pendulum
swung so far to the direction yeah a
regular person saying would you like to
go for a walk with us how dare you you
know I cannot walk more than to my car
anymore yeah now they have Rascals at
Walmart yeah that's the craziest thing
we got we got these wheelchairs at
Walmart sock here leg was broken right
you were old what will help you out
every single time I've ever seen someone
use it it's a fat person yeah it's true
maybe maybe once I saw like an old guy
using it and I was like where yeah but
but but cool man but hold on I get it no
what I look that was supposed to be for
somebody who was disabled or whatever
mm-hmm I still really don't care if it's
a fat person rider on that no that's
true I don't either
whatever man if you can't walk and you
need it yeah okay sure but but we do be
allowed to say it's not healthy sure
it's not healthy but this and even even
that it's like I don't need to go around
telling every fat person to lose weight
did you take the Presidential Fitness
Test in school no what maybe so that was
a thing when I was in school when I was
younger you know you take a physical
fitness test it was like the
presidential standard and you you know
you would be compared across every
school in America it was this thing you
know back in the 90s and I don't know I
was you know they take your body mass
you have the yeah wait what does BMI
exactly and it's like you would see how
you rate it you know if you were above
or below average and whatnot and it's
like they stopped doing that yeah why
why why did they stop doing that because
we don't care about if our kids are
healthy anymore participation trophy era
man yeah I guess so so these are people
who think that they're being victims
because they eat too much like dude no
that is the opposite of a problem it's
like if you want talk about racism dude
I'm down I hear you man
yeah there are some people who are just
bigots definitely no racism is a big
problem change your race yeah there are
things that you can't change and you
don't well there are some people South
Park didn't upset about this I'll avoid
getting us in trouble on YouTube but
anyway don't get us in trouble John King
oh yeah well he just claims it and I
mean but everybody hates that guy
that's ER you know what there's it's
it's called like fin privilege then
privilege the funny thing is they have
just all sorts of privileges right they
keep tacking they don't over word mean
thing privilege I've never heard that
one yeah actually I think what these
people are experiencing is fat privilege
thank you so hmm they can eat whatever
they want whenever they want you know
they're not responsible for their own
health they only have to buy one
airplane seat I don't get it yep they
want they want us to pay for their
health care yes and then they claim to
be the victims talk about privilege yeah
that's look exactly what privilege looks
like I'd love to sit around doing
nothing but eat cheesecake all day
actually that's not true it would not be
entered it would not feel good now that
doesn't sound good to me you know I
can't I think well I think one of the
issues is with a lot with a lot of
people who are overweight mm-hmm I don't
I wonder if the if the problem is that
they're trapped in an addiction
addiction cycle because eating too much
doesn't feel good but I will tell you if
I eat too much I can't skate right it's
like oh man I can't move right and then
you end up not skating so you have to
like eat only a little then you can
skate you get you feel real good you get
that you know you get a runner's high if
you're running or whatever you get the
dopamine from accomplishing your goals
and then exercise actually suppresses
your appetite so you get trapped in the
cycle where you're eating and it makes
you feel bad and you don't want to get
up and move around and you just feel bad
so you eat more yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you